Speaker 1: who would have guessed?
Who would have guessed that if you get vaccinated,
you're very unlikely to catch the coronavirus
because the vaccines are so effective, but
that if you're unvaccinated, especially if
there's lots of unvaccinated people around
you and you're around them indoors without
masks for extended periods of time,
Speaker 2: you
Speaker 1: are more likely to get sick if
a more transmissible variant comes forward.
And that is exactly what is going on right
now.
A new Washington Post report, coronavirus
infections dropping where people are vaccinated,
rising where they are not.
And the article goes into detail to tell us
something that I mean, who would this be a
shock to?
Right.
States with higher vaccination rates now have
markedly fewer coronavirus cases make sense
as infections are dropping in places where
most residents have been immunized and are
rising in many places where people have not.
A Washington Post analysis has found states
with lower vaccination also have significantly
higher hospitalization rates.
Poorly vaccinated communities have not been
reporting catastrophic conditions.
Instead, they're usually seeing new infections
holding steady or increasing without overwhelming
local hospitals.
As recently as 10 days ago, vaccination rates
did not predict the difference in covid cases.
But immunization rates have diverged and case
counts in highly vaccinated states are dropping
quickly.
Vaccination is not even within each state,
the post found the connection between vaccine
shots and covid cases at the local level,
comparing more than one hundred counties with
low vaccination, meaning under 20 percent
vaccinated and more than 700 counties with
high vaccination, meaning at least 40 percent
vaccinated.
And here is the here are the findings and
we're displaying them graphically for you.
Counties with high vaccination had low covid
rates that are going down in counties where
few people are vaccinated.
Not only are there higher rates, but the number
of cases is also growing.
This is in the absolute this is really important
to understand.
If you look at places with fewer vaccinations
and more cases and you see cases above the
national average, these are places like Wyoming,
Idaho, Alabama, Louisiana, Arkansas, West
Virginia, Indiana, Missouri.
What are these places have in common?
I think you understand politically what's
going on there.
You then look at the lower right quadrant
on this graph that we're showing our audience.
The places with more vaccinations have fewer
cases, places like Vermont, Massachusetts,
Hawaii, Connecticut, New Jersey, Rhode Island,
New Hampshire, Pennsylvania, California, Maryland,
DC.
What do these places have in common?
Well, politically, they're very blue.
Now, there are a few outliers.
There are some places with more vaccinations
and also more cases.
There's really four states in that quadrant,
Colorado, Oregon, Washington and Maine.
We're still trying to figure out why that
is.
And we we don't we don't yet know.
So the takeaway here, of course, is go and
get yourself vaccinated.
It's really that simple.
If you want to protect yourself and others,
go and get yourself vaccinated.
And, you know, the the doom and gloom is correct
in unvaccinated communities, a 60 percent
more transmissible variant, which is what
we believe, the Delta Indian variant.
To be at this point in time is going to burn
its way through a population as it finds people
who are not vaccinated when you are vaccinated
because the vaccines are so effective, not
only is it less likely, I mean, how are we
even saying this now?
In June of twenty twenty one, you are less
likely to get sick and people around you were
less likely to get sick because the vaccine
does not guarantee immunity.
It is not 100 percent effective.
We all do something for our community when
we get ourselves vaccinated.
So shocking, right.
Who could have seen it coming that the places
that are more vaccinated are doing better
than the places that are not now as more international
travel resumes.
Spain has or is about to open.
Italy has or is about to open.
France has opened to vaccinated people, et
cetera, will vaccinated travel to countries
that are not yet as vaccinated as the United
States.
Will that increase rates?
I believe that it will not because vaccination
is mostly happening fast enough and the majority
of those countries that things are going to
remain under control, nothing that's happening
is surprising.
And I see people, you know, people on the
left and on the right posting things to to
Twitter and to Facebook, et cetera, as if
anything other than what we're seeing was
predictable.
The place is getting vaccinated quickly, particularly
when you get to 50 percent cases drop like
a lead balloon, a places that are not are
going to continue getting sick, particularly
as these variants spread.
No, no surprise.
Just simply no surprise.
Tell me what you're seeing in your neck of
the woods.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
We have a huge show for you today.
The David Pakman Show is primarily and most
importantly, funded by you guys, and, you
know, I had actually talk a little bit later,
I had some interesting conversations lately
with some other fellow progressive hosts about
some of the drama that's that's going on within
the progressive media community, which I'll
get into later.
And one of the things we all sort of came
together around was, aren't our communities
just great?
Like isn't isn't it incredible that while
there are so many of these left wing communities
being ripped apart by internal drama that
we some of us have been able to build these
communities that are self-sustaining where
the viewers and the listeners are supporting
the work we do, which gives us incredible
freedom that so many people in media dream
of having and never achieve.
So thank you.
And you can sign up today.
Join Pakman Dotcom.
We have a discount code.
Better twenty one.
Use it at your at your pleasure and we make
that available to anybody who wants that coupon
code better.
Twenty one at join Pakman dot com